Imagine, for a moment, that
you could travel backwards through time and
give your sixteen year old self the powers
of a God.
Imagine placing the lives and fates of millions
into your trembling teenage hands.
Would the result be a happier world, a utopia?
Or would the result be catastrophe for everyone
involved, including your younger self?
In October, 54 AD, the Roman Empire made this
little thought experiment a terrifying reality.
They elevated an emotionally unstable 16 year
old boy to the position of emperor.
That boy’s name?
Nero.
The last of the Julio-Claudian emperors, Nero
transformed the greatest empire the world
had ever seen into a playground for his darkest
desires.
He had his own mother murdered, ordered Christians
burned alive for entertainment, and indulged
in perversions so shocking they’d make the
Marquis de Sade blush.
Yet he died beloved by Rome’s commoners,
and convinced he was the greatest artist who
had ever lived.
Join us today as we investigate the life of
the most infamous Roman of all.
Family Ties
If you were to take a quick glance at the
background of Nero, you might assume the emperor
had a childhood of unparalleled luxury.
Born Lucius Domitius Ahenobarbus on December
15, 37 AD, Nero was a member of the Julio-Claudian
dynasty: AKA the dudes who had been ruling
Rome for decades.
His mother, Julia Agrippina –commonly known
as Agrippina the Younger – was a direct
descendant of the first emperor, Augustus.
His uncle was the current emperor, Caligula.
His great-uncle was Claudius.
But while that might sound like a ticket to
life on Roman easy street, Nero’s mother
Agrippina could have told him differently.
The Julio-Claudians enjoyed nothing more than
fratricide.
The rot had started way, way back when Agrippina
herself was just a girl, growing up with her
brother Caligula.
As you’ll know if you’ve already watched
our Caligula video, Agrippina’s dad was
a popular general who was in line for the
imperial throne.
So, naturally, Agrippina’s adopted grandfather,
the emperor Tiberius, had him poisoned in
19 AD.
It was just the first in a long line of Julio-Claudian
family murders.
Jump ahead to 37 AD.
Tiberius is dead and Agrippina’s brother
Caligula inherits the throne.
At first, things were fine.
It was during this period of calm Agrippina
gave birth to Nero.
But then Caligula had one of his trademark
cuckoo moments and decided Agrippina was plotting
to kill him.
So he took all her property and banished her
to a tiny island where she could have no contact
with her son.
Dumped with a random aunt, young Nero was
forced to make do with a dancer as a tutor.
If that sounds actually kinda OK, jut know
that dancers, actors and poets were considered
the lowest of the low in Roman society, no
better than prostitutes.
It seems likely Nero’s aunt felt there was
no point wasting good money on a boy who might
not live long anyway.
Knowing Caligula’s paranoia, it’d be a
miracle if Nero reached his fifth birthday.
Thank Jupiter, that miracle happened.
On 24 January, 41 AD, the elite Praetorian
Guard assassinated Caligula, stabbing him
to death outside the Palatine Games.
They then marched straight to Claudius and
declared him the new emperor.
There was a ‘blink and you’ll miss it’
moment at the start of this video where we
mentioned that Claudius was Nero’s great
uncle.
Well, that meant Agrippina was Claudius’s
niece.
And, unlike Tiberius or Caligula, Emperor
Claudius was all about not killing his relatives.
No sooner had Claudius taken the throne then
he recalled Agrippina from her exile.
At last reunited with her son Nero, Agrippina
swore she would never again be left at the
mercy of her cruel and capricious relatives.
That meant getting her wealth back.
That meant building her own powerbase.
But how was a penniless widow meant to do
that in a patriarchal society like Rome?
You leave that to Agrippina.
First, Agrippina pressured her uncle to find
her a husband, so Claudius forced a consul
to marry her.
Next, Agrippina poisoned that consul and inherited
all his wealth.
Then came 48 AD, and Claudius’s execution
of his wife.
Barely was her body cold than Agrippina was
seducing the emperor’s advisor and giving
him an excellent plan.
Why didn’t Claudius just marry Agrippina?
The proposal was dressed up as a way of uniting
the two Julio-Claudian branches and ending
fratricides once and for all.
But really, it was just an excuse for Agrippina
to get closer to power while Claudius got
to live out his creepy incest fantasies.
On January 1, 49 AD, Agrippina became empress.
One year later, Claudius adopted her son,
Nero.
In ten short years, Agrippina had taken herself
and Nero from pariahs to the heart of imperial
Rome.
They had money, power.
But never forget that Agrippina was from a
family that prided itself on killing useless
members.
And what use did empress Agrippina now have
for her uncle Claudius?
Where the Monster was Nurtured
Come 51 AD, all was not well in Rome’s imperial
palace.
That same year, Agrippina had pressured Claudius
into naming Nero his co-heir, alongside the
emperor’s natural son Britannicus.
With Nero suddenly in line for half the throne,
Claudius’s advisors were taking a closer
look at him.
They didn’t like what they saw.
By now a teenager, Nero was a sulky, spoiled
brat who would rather spend his time learning
to play the lyre than learning how to rule.
Worse still, the boy was developing a cruel
streak.
One by one, people started to wonder if they
might not have another Caligula on their hands.
Yet they were powerless to stop Agrippina
building her son’s powerbase.
In 53 AD, Agrippina forced Nero into marriage
with Claudia Octavia, a daughter of Claudius.
When we say “forced”, we really mean it.
Claudia Octavia was being perused by another
suitor at the time.
Agrippina wrecked that courtship and drove
the suitor to suicide.
Yet even this marriage of convenience wasn’t
enough to convince Agrippina that she was
safe, that another Caligula wouldn’t come
along and drive her into poverty again.
The only way to do that would be to make herself
answerable to no-one.
On 13 October, 54 AD, Emperor Claudius suddenly
died.
Ancient sources speculate that Agrippina bribed
the emperor’s taster and slipped him poisoned
mushrooms.
Whether that’s true or not, the results
were the same.
Control of the empire went to Claudius’s
heirs: Nero and Britannicus.
Or rather, it should have.
At the moment Claudius died, only Nero was
old enough to be considered an adult.
Britannicus was still a child, legally incapable
of ruling.
So when Agrippina presented Nero alone to
the Praetorian Guard and asked them to salute
their new emperor, there was nothing Britannicus
could do.
Aged only 16, Nero was elevated to sole ruler
of the world’s most powerful empire.
Let’s take a second to imagine how Agrippina
must have felt that day.
Against all the odds, she’d overcome a childhood
of tragedy and an adulthood of exile to install
herself at the heart of Rome.
She’d murdered her second husband.
She’d manipulated and killed an emperor.
And now her son was on the throne.
We hope Agrippina savored that moment.
Really, we do.
Because it wasn’t destined to last long.
Just as his mother had started to wonder if
she really needed Claudius, the new Emperor
Nero was starting to wonder if he really needed
Agrippina.
Before long, Agrippina found herself being
slowly pushed out the corridors of power.
Determined to fight, the wily murderess tried
to ally herself with Britannicus, only for
Nero to have his stepbrother poisoned.
Not long after, Agrippina was moved out the
palace to a little villa on the outskirts
of Rome.
Even the precious marriage she’d secured
for Nero with Claudia Octavia was destroyed,
as Nero took up instead with Poppaea Sabina.
As a last ditch effort, Agrippina made overtures
to Nero’s cousin, suggesting they could
depose the teenage emperor together.
But Agrippina’s luck had already run out.
In early 59 AD, Nero had Agrippina board a
boat that was designed to sink and drown her.
When she managed to survive the grueling swim
to shore, her son simply ordered her stabbed
to death.
It’s said that as she realized what was
about to happen, Agrippina pointed at her
womb and screamed “Stab me there, where
the monster had been nurtured!”
Julia Agrippina died on March 23, 59 AD.
After the news leaked out, Nero half-assedly
tried to tell everyone it had been a suicide.
But no-one in Rome was under any illusions.
The young emperor had broken the greatest
taboo, killing his own mother.
Claudius’s advisors had been wrong.
Nero wasn’t the next Caligula.
He was something much, much worse.
The Artistic Emperor
You probably have a mental checklist prepared
for the rest of this video.
Fiddling as Rome burns: check.
Persecuting the Christians: check.
Well, don’t worry, we’ll get to those
dubious highlights.
But before we tell you about Nero the Crazy
Emperor, we’ve got to tell you about Nero
the Insanely Popular Emperor.
That’s right: popular.
For all his name may now be synonymous with
decadence, Nero started his reign actually
being quite a cool sorta dude.
Prior to Agrippina’s death, Nero had banned
secret trials, cracked down on corruption,
and handed powers back to the Senate.
He also slashed taxes, banned capital punishment,
granted more rights to slaves, banned animal
bloodsports, and tried to phase out gladiatorial
combat and replace it with Greek wrestling.
So popular were these measures, the great
emperor Trajan would later declare Nero’s
first five years the greatest reign in Roman
history.
Here we finally reach one of the contradictions
surrounding Nero.
Despite all the mad stuff he did, he was beloved
by his subjects.
Nero had a common touch other Roman elites
lacked.
After his death, a whole generation of ambitious
provincials would claim to be Nero’s heirs
as a shortcut to popularity.
Why, then, do we only hear about the bad stuff?
Maybe because the common folk didn’t write
the histories.
Neither did the ambitious provincials, but
the monied, Roman elite.
And those guys couldn’t stand the way Nero
debased his office.
The issue was that, unlike Augustus, Tiberius,
or Caligula, Nero had never wanted to be emperor.
It was Agrippina who had schemed him into
the palace, into power.
The other reluctant emperor, Claudius, had
at least been old enough to understand the
responsibilities of office.
Nero was young enough to understand the responsibilities
of office could kiss his Roman ass.
Not long after Agrippina’s death, Nero talked
openly about giving up the throne to become
a full time poet.
But the power that came with being a living
God was simply too much fun, so instead Nero
began to live an artist’s life parallel
to his imperial one.
The young emperor spent his spare time partying
in brothels, carousing with actors, hanging
out with lowlifes.
He liked to get drunk and appear onstage in
theaters, sometimes in female roles.
Remember: the Romans thought artists were
lower than sex workers.
Seeing Nero indulge his artistic side for
them was like seeing the Queen of England
dance naked for cash in an Amsterdam brothel.
Although given what happened next, a better
monarchial comparison might be Henry VIII.
In 62 AD, Nero’s mistress Poppaea Sabina
became pregnant.
Since Nero was still married to the popular
Claudia Octavia, this caused a scandal.
So Nero divorced Claudia and banished her
into exile, an underhand move that was about
to get even more underhanded.
When the people of Rome protested her banishment,
Nero had his ex-wife murdered.
It was the second time he’d killed a close
relative and, just as with Agrippina, Nero
vaguely made out like it had been a suicide.
In reality, it was yet another bloodstain
on the artist-emperor’s hands.
It wouldn’t be the last.
Let the Mother Burn
By July 18, 64 AD, Emperor Nero’s initial
popularity was in terminal nosedive.
The same year Nero had Claudia murdered, the
Praetorian Guard prefect Burrus had died.
A natural moderate, he’d kept the emperor’s
darkest desires in check.
So what did Nero do?
He replaced him with a guy called Tigellinus
who thought the best thing the emperor could
do with his dark desires was let them loose.
That meant orgies.
Bloody purges of the elite.
Even fewer hecks given about respecting the
office of emperor.
Come that hot July of 64 AD, the people of
Rome were fed up with their emperor and ready
to believe anything about him.
Into this tinderbox of resentment came a very
real spark.
The causes of the Great Fire of Rome are lost
to history.
All we know is that, on July 18, a conflagration
swept through the Eternal City.
At the time, Rome was a collection of wooden
shacks that had been thrown up without any
central plan.
So when the inferno got going, it really got
going.
The fire burned for a week.
By the time it fizzled, three of the city’s
districts had been destroyed, and the imperial
palace itself had been damaged.
And what was Emperor Nero doing while all
this destruction took place?
That’s absolutely…
Wrong.
Yep, the one thing everyone knows about Nero,
that he fiddled as Rome burned, turns out
to be total bunk.
Nero wasn’t even in the city at the time.
Far from regarding the fire as a source of
amusement, Tacitus tells us Nero raced back
to the Rome and spearheaded the relief efforts.
He even let hundreds of those left homeless
by the disaster stay in the imperial palace.
This kinda raises the question: why do we
all think Nero fiddled as Rome burned?
Two reasons.
One involves a building, the other a Jewish
cult.
Let’s tackle the building first.
Once the fire was over, Nero pledged to rebuild
Rome grander than before.
In most respects, he succeeded, constructing
a new city with streets wide enough to hinder
future fires.
However, he also decided to build a massive
palace atop the rubble.
A palace that included a 120ft tall statue
of himself.
For a Roman public that was already leaning
anti-Nero, this was too much.
Rumors started to swirl that Nero had set
the fire himself, specifically so he could
build his stupid palace.
Panicked, Nero decided he needed to find someone
else to blame fast.
His chosen scapegoats were a Jewish sect known
as the Christians.
In 64 AD, Rome’s Christians were a small
cult, comprising of non-citizens, refugees,
and Greek-speaking outsiders.
Like foreigners, refugees, and immigrants
sadly discover all too frequently, that made
them perfect targets.
On Nero’s orders, prominent Christians were
tortured until they confessed to starting
the fire.
Nero then set about having all of them rounded
up and gruesomely executed.
Unlike the tale of the Nero fiddling, all
the stories you’ve heard about his torture
of the Christians are true.
Christians really were torn apart by wild
animals.
Nero really did have them burned alive to
illuminate his garden parties.
Perhaps it’s no wonder early Christians
came to seriously hate Nero.
There’s a theory that the Antichrist in
the Book of Revelation was meant to symbolize
the emperor.
But it wasn’t just the Christians who disliked
Nero’s persecution.
The extreme tortures inflicted were disturbing
even by Roman standards.
In the Senate and the Praetorian Guard, people
began to whisper to one another that maybe
things were getting out of hand.
That it was time to get rid of their arsonist
emperor.
They hadn’t counted on just how hard to
kill Nero would turn out to be.
The Horrors of Love
When people want to prove just what a monster
Nero was, they usually point to his actions
in 64 AD: allegedly letting Rome burn, and
actually slaughtering the Christians.
Really, they should point to the emperor’s
antics the following year.
If 64 AD was Nero at his most misunderstood,
65 AD was Nero at his psychotic peak.
It started when the Senate plot against Nero
was discovered.
What followed was a purge that saw 23 conspirators
forced to commit suicide, among them the philosopher
Seneca.
But if 23 dead doesn’t sound so bad, know
that this was just the warm up act.
In the wake of the conspiracy, Nero brought
back the treason trials that had been such
a feature of Tiberius and Caligula’s rules.
Kangaroo courts that convicted and executed
people on a whim, the treason trials were
infamous for being an underhand way for the
emperor to get rid of anyone he didn’t like.
And Nero in 65 AD had an enemies list longer
than War and Peace.
Yet even this bloodshed doesn’t compare
to Nero’s cruelest act that year.
At some point that summer, Nero got in a blazing
row with his wife, Poppaea Sabina.
Remember her?
The mistress who got pregnant, causing Nero
to murder his previous wife?
Well, Poppaea probably should have realized
that ordering your wife’s assassination
isn’t a great sign of mental stability.
According to Tacitus, Nero, mad with rage,
kicked Poppaea to death.
The poor girl was pregnant at the time, and
Nero made sure to aim his vicious kicks at
her swollen stomach.
In the aftermath of this brutal double murder,
Nero went insane.
He had Poppaea stuffed and embalmed and her
corpse deposited in a mausoleum so he could
visit it whenever he wanted.
Freakier still, Nero caught sight of a 13
year old boy a few weeks later who was the
spitting image of his murdered wife.
Known as Sporus, this unlucky boy was kidnapped
by Nero’s men and castrated.
Nero then forced Sporus to dress in clothes
belonging to the dead Poppaea, and married
him in a bizarre service.
After that, Sporus could be seen, dressed
and acting like the dead empress, sat at Nero’s
side as the deranged emperor kissed and fondled
him.
If this wasn’t already creepy enough, Nero
himself took to wearing a Poppaea mask when
he performed onstage, embodying the girl whose
life he’d so viciously snatched away.
Yet even as he drifted into Norman Bates territory,
Nero didn’t lose his common touch.
The next year, 66 AD, he left on a tour of
Rome’s eastern provinces, effectively giving
himself a year’s break from running the
empire.
But rather than react to this creepy murderer
the way the elites in Rome had, those in the
east acted like Nero was an ancient rock star.
The thing was, Nero knew how to play a crowd.
In Greece, he dressed like an ascetic, with
bare feet and flowing hair, and took an active
interest in the country’s new religions.
Wherever he went, he granted towns “free
city” status, ensuring the inhabitants celebrated
him.
He was so popular that he even took part in
the Olympic Games.
Unsurprisingly, he won every event he entered.
It seems Nero himself felt being in the east
was a form of freedom.
He began appearing on stage more and more,
often playing the roles of pregnant women.
When word got back to Rome, upper society
was more scandalized than ever.
But Nero was wrong if he thought he could
just keep violating norms and doing whatever
the hell he felt like.
The emperor didn’t know it yet, but his
days on this earth were already numbered.
“What an Artist Dies in Me”
In early 68 AD, Nero sent an order to the
governor of Gaul, a guy called Vindex, telling
him to raise local taxes.
It was just one of many such orders Nero was
in the habit of sending out to fund his lavish
lifestyle.
But this time something was different.
Nero didn’t know it, but Vindex was at breaking
point.
Fed up with endlessly having to raise taxes
on Gaul, Vindex snapped when he saw Nero’s
latest demand.
He took up arms and declared himself in rebellion
against the emperor.
But then he did a funny thing.
He declared allegiance to the popular governor
of Spain, a guy named Galba.
This was funny because Galba was very much
not in rebellion.
When he heard of Vindex’s declaration, he
freaked out and declared himself for Nero.
But just hearing Vindex mention Galba was
enough to send Nero’s paranoia into overdrive.
He had both men declared enemies of Rome.
Realizing he was doomed either way, Galba
went “ah, screw it” and declared he was
in rebellion after all.
Unfortunately for Nero, a popular governor
leading a rebellion was exactly the news Rome
had been waiting for.
As news of Galba’s revolt hit, the Praetorian
Guard came out in support of him.
As did the Senate.
As did a huge swathe of the army.
As did… well, everyone.
On the night of June 9, 68 AD, Nero woke up
to find his palace empty.
Sensing the end was near, everyone had deserted
the emperor.
As Nero ran through the empty, cavernous rooms,
he screamed first for help, and then for someone
to kill him.
When no voices came in reply, Nero is said
to have wailed “have I neither friend nor
foe?”
But the emperor was wrong.
He had plenty of foes.
Across the city, the Senate had called an
emergency meeting.
Seeing which way the wind was blowing, they
declared Nero an enemy of Rome and dispatched
soldiers to finish him off.
But Nero was no longer in his palace.
Accompanied by a handful of slaves and one
freedman, Nero had fled to a darkened villa
four miles outside the Eternal City.
Had he been able to make it to the east of
the empire, where he was still popular, he
may have stood a chance.
But that chance slipped through his fingers,
and now there was only one way this could
end.
As the soldiers closed in on his hiding place,
Nero is said to have started muttering to
himself “what an artist dies in me!”
He demanded his slaves kill him, but to no
avail.
Finally, with the soldiers right outside and
dawn finally breaking, Nero snatched a dagger
from someone and plunged it deep into his
own throat.
The soldiers stormed in to find the emperor
knelt on the floor, his tunic soaked with
blood.
With what we imagine must have been an unhinged
grin on his face, Nero supposedly delivered
one last, immortal line to the men sent to
kill him:
“Too late.”
Emperor Nero died that morning, unloved and
alone, a pariah to his people.
With his death, the Julio-Claudian line that
had ruled Rome since it became an empire was
snuffed out.
The fratricidal family that had given the
world the highs of Augustus and the lows of
Caligula would produce no more emperors.
But if anyone was expecting Nero’s death
to herald an era of stability, they were in
for a rude awakening.
In the wake of Nero’s suicide, Galba was
made emperor.
But he ruled a mere six months before being
assassinated.
Galba’s death would plunge the empire into
chaos.
69 AD would see four emperors come and go
before the dust settled and Vespasian claimed
the throne.
But all of that is for another video.
What of Nero?
What of the man we came here to discuss?
Although he’s infamous today as the most
decadent emperor, you could argue that Nero
wasn’t the worst.
Sure, he did some terrible, inhuman things.
But even his cruelest acts weren’t the outright
sadism of Caligula, as much as they were the
lashings out of an angry teenage boy who never
mentally grew up.
It’s true that Nero was a nasty man and
an unhinged pervert.
But it’s also true that his badness is sometimes
exaggerated.
He never fiddled while Rome burned.
The first years of his rule were even something
of a golden age.
While it’s fitting that we remember the
awful, vicious side of Nero, it’s also worth
remembering that history is more nuanced than
it often appears.
Nero was deranged, but hopefully in our video
today we’ve shown there was more to him
than simply being Rome’s crazy emperor.